hi my name is Chris Stedman I'm here to
talk to you about something very
important today the flourishing movie
reviewing community of YouTube is being
overrun with men who can take up the
camera take up the editing software and
broadcast their opinion to the world
there is an ever-growing need for women
to take up that camera take up your
weapon and film your opinion and
broadcast yourself to the world I am in
search of the next great female movie
reviewer if you are a girl take that
camera take that computer make a video
express the thoughts that you have on
film take your desire to express your
opinion to the next level
and bring your thoughts to the YouTube
reviewing community I am not satisfied
with an 85 percent male demographic on
my videos I want women I don't mean that
in a bad way
this video is to encourage women all
around the world of different ages races
ethnicities beliefs religions everything
to take up that video camera and
broadcast their opinions on film the
community is overrun by men by myself
being one of them and we need more women
so we can feel less like nerds I'm Chris
Sutton and this message has been
approved I mean
do it